مشاهدينا نبدا المنتصف باخر التطورات
الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت الاداره
الاداره العسكريه لمدينه يافا ان قوات
الدفاع الجوي اسقطت مسيرات الانتحاريه في
احدث هجوم روسيه على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
واضافتنا حطام احدى الطائرات الحق اضرار
بمبنيين اداريين في حي شفيان في وسط
العاصمه ودعي اوليكس كوليبا رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في كياف المواطنين للبقاء في
الملاجئ مع استمرار الخطر متيما روسيا بما
وصفه بمواصله ارهابي الطاقه
دنيا سمير
13 مسيره من نوع وشاهد دمرت جميع الطائرات
بواسطه الدفاعات الجويه نشكر قوات الدفاع
على انجازهم وارجو من الجميع الالتزامات
بقواعد الانذار الجوي
وفي الجبهه الشرقيه خلاص
الاداره العسكريه والاقليميه في اقليم
القوات الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره على 13
قريه وبلده في الاقليم متوقعا مزيدا من
التقدم مع بدايه العام وفي الجنوب اعلنت
سلطات وخيرسون الاوكرانيه عن مقتل مدني
واصابه اخرين في قصف روسيا على المقاطعه
من جهه ثانيه اعلنت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه مقتل جنود روس في لوغان
الشرقيه البلاد واصابه عشرات اخرين في
معارك زبوجيا وقالت هيئه ان قوتها دمرت
مقرا لقياده الاركان الروسيه
في المقابل قالت السلطات المحليه المواليه
لروسيا في دنيا خمسه اشخاص قتلوا خلال
ساعات الماضيه في قصف الاوكراني على مناطق
في المقاطعه وتشهد محاور دنيتك منذ صباح
اليوم تبادل مكثفا للقصف المدفعي بين
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه زعيم
الانفصاليين في دنيازك وصف القصف الذي
تعرضت له دميه خلال الايام الماضيه بانه
الاعنف مضيفا ان القوات الاوكرانيه تواجه
ضربات منتظمه كل يوم تتجاوز المرتين يوميا
نتابع الوضع الميداني من كيف مع مراسله
الجزيره عامر لافي ومن خرد سيسك في دنياك
مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر ونبدا مع عامر
لافي ولاجمات التي تحدث عنها الجانب
الاوكراني بالمسيرات على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كياب
الرئيس الاوكراني بالامس كان قد حذر
المواطنين وتحديدا سكان كيف بان توقف
القصف عن هذه المدينه لا يعني ان الروس قد
تراجع عن قصفها واستهدافها وانما وفقا
للرئيسكي هذا استعداد لضربه جديده ويبدو
ان مجرى اليوم هو بالفعل هذه الضربه
الجديده التي كان يتوقعها الرئيس المسكين
خلفي تماما هو المبنى الذي قالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه بانه المبنى الذي سقط عليه
حطام المسيره او احدى المسيارات التي
تستهدفت العاصمه هنا كياب طبعا همم
السلطات الاوكرانيه تقول بان العاصمه
السعوديه بثلاثه عشر مسيره من نوع شاهد
ايرانيه الصنع وانها هاجمه المدينه على
شكل دفعتين وانه اسقط كل هذه الطائرات هذا
المبنى حسن هو مبنى تابع لشرطه الضرائب في
العاصمه كيف المبنى فارغ لان ضربه كانت
حوالي الساعه السادسه فجرا هل هذا الحي
الذين يتحدثنا معهم قالوا لنا او وصفوا
انفسهم بانهم محظوظين لانه على بعد امطار
بسيطه من هذا المبنى يوجد حي سكني مكتظ
وربما لو هذه الغربه او هذه الشضايا سقطت
على هذه المباني فالربما كان سيكون هناك
عدد من الضحايا وربما القتلى او الجرحى
بين صفوف المدنيين للعلم طبعا وفقا لدائره
الطوارئ الاوكرانيه لا يوجد قتلى او جرح
جرار هذا الهجوم الذي استهدف العاصمه هنا
في قلب العاصمه حي شبشينكا وايضا في غرب
العاصمه ايضا كان هناك استهداف لكن كما
ذكرنا اسقطت كل هذه الطائرات بالنسبه
للطائرات المسيره هنا لابد من الاشاره الى
ما ذكرته اليوم القوات المسلحه وتحديدا
قياده القوات الجويه التي قالت بان روسيا
اشترت حوالي او اكثر من 1700 مسيره من نوع
شاهد من ايران وانها استلمت 400 من هذه
المسيارات وانى تصل هذه الطائرات على شكل
دفعات هذا الموضوع كان قد طرح قبل اربعه
ايام عندما اعلنت قيا القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه عن استئناف استخدام هذه
المسيارات بعد توقف ثلاثه اسابيع هنا في
وسائل الاعلام المراقبين دار الحديث عن
انه قد تم اسقاطه واستخدام كل الدفعات
والان بدات روسيا تستلم دفعات جديده من
هذه الطائرات واعادت لاستخدامها ضد
المنشات الحيويه ومشات الطاقه في كيف
العديد من المقاطعات الاوكرانيه